i've heard of release study i haven't
used it usually my
learn or review openings i actually
don't
personally like the move trainer i just
like kind of using the arrow key to
browse through the lines and
internalize that way okay let's play
e4 but i have heard like good things
about least study
and chassible
okay play play a tricky line
oh no that was a mouse slip take back
i meant to play bishop c4 oh opponent is
so kind
okay also thank you fast jorge
subbing at tier one
a very kind opponent
okay now it's time to take him down
bishop g6 was that a mouse slip
kind of strange move unplayable though
now i'm hitting the pawn i guess e5
the thing is i kind of want black to
play e5 like even though it gains some
space
reinforces d4 it opens up my bishop
also gives me the square for the knight
d3 is very natural
[Music]
yeah i really enjoy the sort of
structure
simple plan this castling f4 queen h4
and causing some kingside concern
there's this move
yeah so i'm kind of switching out my
plans block hating my f pawn but
it's not clear how black actually
defends this thing
because knight h6 i take it
f6 i guess it's playable
there is an interesting idea just to
move the knight back
and now i'm threatening i'm threatening
to take the knight
and then play g3 removing the queen from
defending f6
there's queen h5 here but then i can
take return to g3
enjoy life
okay so there's g3 again let's play c3
again i have to play quickly
also just trying to keep the pressure
keep improving
bishop g4 does hit my queen and probably
just move over
oh there's a nice idea bishop g4 i play
this move and after the trade
i'm threatening the pawn but also
threatening to take and win the other
pawn
the black's a bit stuck there
that's a move okay now i'll
start targeting f5 square again
okay i could trade
attempting to trade queens here because
it's nice positional advantage
i think i'll do it keep things simple
because i still have ways to exert
pressure
mainly h4
bishop g4 and bishop g4 there's a funny
line knight g7 king i f8
rook b7 swift takes and i take the
bishop
let's still play h4
now black pieces are a bit restricted
uh this is actually really really fun
now
the king has no moves i'm guaranteed
some discovery
i might have some mating that
um is it me is it made in two
no it's not meeting two but it's winning
if here it's maiden yeah that's meat wow
that was a cool like mating attack kind
of unexpected there
was a nice kind of instructive game got
some uh
some kind of positional play with
eventual tactics on the king's side
um i think the problems
stemmed from e5 yeah computer saying
bishop
c5 because after e5 the pieces just they
came in nicely
i was not expecting to meet especially
after the queen trade
like so soon yeah there's king f7 here
but i take with double check and win
material
okay thanks for the game sg plus also
thanks for the take back
that was so kind
i usually don't offer take backs usually
it's just not a question and bullets but
sometimes if there's a clear mouse slip
it's uh it's worth a try
i wouldn't have been too salty if my
opponent declined to take back